hmm no no we're live
and no i'm live
yeah episode four with infinite bra
frank
yang this time on the nature of
mind
i think we've been talking about the
nature of mind for the last uh ten years
but this one is about the nature of the
nature of the mind
frank i feel like it'll be good for us
to
just dive right into
this so
when we
approach this question what is the
nature of mind
typically what immediately confuses
people is that they're they're not
they're no longer looking for a thing
and this seems to be the biggest
confusion for people
is that they're not looking for a thing
so when when you start
looking at the nature of mind you
immediately become
uh infused
into uh what looks like a big
cloud of concepts thoughts
ideas your name your career your family
your ambitions all of these
attributes to your identity basically is
what sort of
and these are all like symbols and
concepts
and stuff like that and so then
now you're already playing with the
formless you're playing with symbols and
concepts and identity and ideas and
there's
no it's not like a pen that's a thing
that you can point at
so
so many of the of the traditions
talk about this especially the buddhist
tradition zokchen
and vajrayana
the nature of mind being an empty
cognizance so
i would like for frank to reflect to us
about sort of where um i'll speak about
this for a moment and we'll see how
frank
reflects to this so once you do turn in
word and you begin seeing that
formlessness
the first sort of uh
way of of recognizing that formlessness
is that it's an there's it's an
emptiness or like a spaceness
to it like like space
but yet there's a cognizant quality
to it where you have the power to know
so mind is both empty space-like
and is suffused with awareness
this quality the power to know to
cognize
so let's have you reflect to us sort of
how you see that initial turn towards
the nature of mind
um away from things and towards this
formless
and then seeing it as this sort of this
empty cognizance yeah
so you have to first distinguish between
um thoughts see you have to uh first
sort of clarify what we mean by the mind
because
that's why i used to use the word mind a
lot but i don't use that anymore
ever since like the big bang i stopped
using where mine so much
it's because um people get confused
because when you say the mind they start
to think about the brain or even
thoughts and if you look at thoughts
thoughts are not formless
even though at the ultimate level
everything is formless because formal
emptiness
are identical but before you become
non-dual there is a distinction between
uh form and emptiness so thoughts on the
sort of
relative level are still objects they're
still uh
forms so when you say mind people
before they glimpse this ultimate nature
of
experience whatever this is everywhere
um they're gonna start thinking about
the mind
the personal mind the ego mind the brain
they immediately go into their head
and they start looking at their thoughts
and it gets
really confusing because let's just say
i've never
ever if i'm in the state right now uh
the clinical natural state even the
natural state that the term is really
confusing because people are like oh the
natural state
i'm in a natural state right now but the
natural state before you actually access
uh non-dual awareness and the natural
the clinical natural state before that
in the natural state of downtown
awareness is actually uh
that's a quantum difference to it the
analogy i like to use is washing the
screen versus being in the screen
but anyway that's another point uh the
nature of mind so
uh if i've never read the definition of
mind on a dictionary
and then someone tell me hey this is the
mind they swim in the dictionary and
they start explaining what the mind is
um i would not think this has anything
to do with the mind or the brain at all
because
this experience right here right now um
i would never for a million years think
that it's the product of the brain or
the mind
i don't think it's product of i don't
know i can't really describe it
i wouldn't even say it's a product of
god it's just there's no words to
describe
it at all so that's why mt
cognizance is kind of like a pretty good
term
yeah um because it's formless
it's colorless shapeless odorless
has no depth no dimension no width
it's like space it's not really exactly
like space because space
uh is sort of still something still is
still some form that arises
as uh the manifestation of this clinical
empty
cognizance and uh he has no time
uh even infinity it doesn't really quite
describe it either but i use the word
infinity a lot because it's the closest
to it in my direct experience because
it's boundless
it's completely still uh it's
spontaneous
so first we have to do
uh i think the first thing we have to do
is clarify what you mean by the mind
so to avoid confusion of when we talk
about this stuff and people look at to
start looking at their thoughts and
start examining thoughts because you
can't
you can never get to the the bottom of
what the mind clinical mind is by
looking at by using the mind you can
only
understand the mind the nature of mind
by transcending the mind
that's why all those philosophers um for
like you know decades and
uh centuries are arguing over the nature
of
mind and consciousness but it doesn't
they seem like they're going to circle
in a sense
because they're trying to use logic
they're trying to use concept they're
trying to use the mind
to understand the mind they use a logic
to understand logic they use concept to
understand concept
and that's never going to work because
what you know god deals uh
incompleteness you know if you use the
system to
look at itself there's always going to
be a blind spot that's why you have to
go above the level of whatever system
you're in
to be able to understand it
and then by this point even the more
understanding
misses the point because it's not really
something that you understand because
understanding
presupposes that there's some kind of
like conceptual elements in there
it's more like just no i think
knowing is a better word just like uh
comprehending or apprehending
apprehending like the uh the nature of
reality uh mind
i'm gonna use all those words
interchangeably reality
my consciousness awareness and peacocks
[Music]
to me they're all the same word or some
people like to call it god or love
whatever but
uh there might be a little too many uh
connotations to those words as well so
um the way that um reality or experience
just experience the way that experience
just experiences itself
the way that reality just knows itself
comprehends itself yeah
perfect probably a better way to
describe what's going on right
yeah yes okay
so there's another way to approach this
to be helpful for people is to
sort of inquire logically
how reality is comprehending itself
so how does the universe comprehend
itself
and when you begin going down that
line of reasoning you start recognizing
that okay
so mind in this
way that we're describing it is how
the universe is comprehending itself
so if we are
the unbounded pure potential
that we can never come to the end of
exploring
and we are eternal in that sense
infinite in that sense
then this universe is a
manifestation to explore
some of that infinite potential
and the way that we are comprehending
the exploration
the play the dance that this universe is
the song
that it is is through
mind all of the complexities from the
crazy amounts of planets that are
orbiting stars that have evolved life
all the way to specifically this planet
and
the 10 million species that are on it
the geopolitical relations between the
us
and china the the name
all of the different unique name that
each one of these pieces of
life had ascribed to it
and so now you're beginning to kind of
turn you're turning the fabric
of reality on itself to ask
about its nature so when when we ask
about the nature of mind we're basically
turning
the the fabric of reality on itself
where rather than
being on the stage and just
doing the play now we're wondering well
what is the point of like if we took the
perspective of the audience watching the
play
why is the play happening and how is the
play being comprehended
how is it being understood and so
so then if it seems like the big switch
for people as they undergo this process
of
understanding okay i'm i'm getting the
nature of the universe is comprehended
by
mind and then they're like okay but now
mind is not a thing
mind is not a pen it's not a marker
it's not an object instead
mind is this weird turn inward
and so i just want to clarify quick
because when people
turn inward they typically hit things
like
thought and name and identity
and emotion and belief and
experience and all these things so you
said that
thought you when you get to these
advanced levels you can objectify
thought you can turn it into an object
but
but for most people would you say that
the beginning of like being aware
of a thought arising is in itself
formless
isn't it when the thought arises in the
beginning stages
you can see that as a formless arising
like a cloud
appearing is that also how you view it
um at first at first for me thoughts are
quite solidified when i started first
started meditating i i wouldn't think of
thoughts as formless
like i would when i observed thoughts i
they were just like objects to me
um when i say objectify i mean just
identifying from it
not that yeah it's not that um turned
into an object well it is kind of like
that but it's more just like this
identify you you object just like
you know when you look at some people
criticize certain movies for
objectifying women
um you do those things you do those bad
things to women
because you look at women like objects
you look at them as you know
separate from what you are that's for me
is objectifying
and the whole process of uh
understanding the nature of mind
uh for me or at least at the more
advanced level is to objectify
everything even you know even the
subject even
awareness even consciousness thoughts
feelings emotions
side sound the whole world once you
objectify everything in your
field of experience there's no more room
for subject the subject completely
vanished
uh and when the subject vanished the
object also vanished
um and there's no more duality and
that's non-duality
um but when you first start when i first
started to meditate i watched my
thoughts i i didn't see anything much of
it i i wasn't analyzing thoughts as you
know other objects are they're formless
is this the nature of mind that i was
just like okay this is my thoughts i'm
watching it because that's what i do in
meditation
um so i can't speak for everyone
but the reason why i mentioned thoughts
are like objects and they're also
forms because there is a difference
between this empty cognis
uh this empty uh cognizing uh formless
you know just the pure knowing the
essence of
and uh the manifestations
yeah ultimately they're the same because
ultimately the source and appearance of
the
manifesto and the memphis are one uh but
at the midway stage
uh it's important to make that
distinction and how like okay thoughts
are also just formed so no different
from objects
in the on the real world perfect so
so let's let's do this let's do this
again
where we initially we make the turn from
these quote physical objects
to what is a little bit more formless
which is the thought or
or an identity or emotion or belief or
experience
and then the next question as you sort
of become
observant of those
more formless so you've shifted away
from the
physical objects towards something
that's more formless
now you're becoming you're being you're
gaining metacognition
so that's another probably very
important
um mainstream word for this i'll put
that down
as well for people what you're talking
about now um so yeah
thoughts that whatever it's in the in
the in the mind are a little bit more
i wouldn't say i would call it less
solidified so
someone one of my clients asked me what
is the point of the spiritual path
though can you describe the spiritual
probably one sentence and i was like
you're trying to uh um make everything
you experience
less and less solidified so a pen
object out there in the real world is
very solidified
but when you start looking inward um or
when you scan the body at first the body
is very solidified it's an object
but once you start to to do like your
passion on meditation
and you try to you know skin the body
once you start put awareness on the body
start to dissolve
first it was solidified and then it
becomes like liquid
that's when you enter the jaundice and
then it becomes like uh smoke and then
air and then finally the empty kungus
but they realize actually they're all
the same thing because forming engineers
at one so you shift back and forth
um
let's keep breaking it down by stages i
see that you're you're going
you're you're getting you're spreading
the whole spectrum right off of
um each one of the sort of trains of of
beautiful expression of yours
so again so we made it we made the shift
from
the these more physical
objects right towards
what is more formless which is a
a thought or a symbol or a concept or an
emotion or an experience
and so what you're doing is you're
gaining metacognition
right here metacognition because
what's what's happening is you're
becoming
aware of your thinking and
when you become aware of your thinking
you're in a sense you're gaining some
sovereignty
you're gaining will you're gaining
choice
you're gaining awareness from what used
to be more
scripted style of behaviors
to something that in a sense when you do
something as simple as just
take a deep inhalation you feel for a
moment you're like
you gain awareness you gain a little bit
more
insight into what is formless the
quality of the power to know
versus when you were fixated on a
thought or an
object so okay so we went from fixated
on objects
to now fixated on thoughts so now the
thoughts are appearing and disappearing
like clouds in this empty space like
sky-ness that we're talking about here
as the
the nature of mind and so you're gaining
metacognition you're gaining insight
into watching as these clouds
appear and disappear and you're not
so now this is the key frank let me know
if you feel like this is the key
the word non-fixation
would you say that that's sort of the
key
non-fixation there so
would you say that the key is to not
fixate on the appearances within
mind and then to recognize what is the
space
in which the appearances
appear and disappear is that would you
say that's key
yes that's exactly the distinction i was
making earlier how uh when you are in
that space watching thoughts
that space is more formless than the
thoughts
thoughts become an object in the space
and the pen becomes an object in the
space
even space itself is arising in that
space of non-space
or time actually the entire universe
um for you at least is uh vibrating
out of that space of no space
yeah yes okay so great so frank just
made that further distinction for us
so now where you saw this pen
as an object this marker as an object
you've shifted
internally into this kingdom of
consciousness of mind within
and now you're watching from
here you're watching more and more of
your thoughts appear and disappear
and you're not fixating on them when
they appear
and you're recognizing that the space
the mind essence in which
the thoughts appear and disappear in
which the
in which the marker appears and
disappears
in that space like yes
empty both empty so the space-like
emptiness of it
but then there's also this because when
you turn in you notice it's not
a thing it's no thing
it's not a thing if right now it's not
even nothing
not even nothing if you
if you just turn your attention
on attention itself you'll notice that
whatever mystery or magic that
attention or mind is is
not a thing it's no thing
and so okay so so you have that first
and then you have the cognizant
quality to it which means that it has
this power to know
right now you can go marker ah
power to know marker or power to know
thought i love
frank power to know i love frank
so there's a thought or i love water
another thought i will drink water
cognizant
and so now you have empty cognizance as
this nature of mind and now
you might ask the next question around
this
which is might empty cognizance
might this formless power to know
this empty formless power to know might
that
be god
that would be the next so that's the
that's the
that's the distinction between whether
that the empty space to know
uh is really the nature of reality or is
it something that's
generated by the brain uh there's no
answer to this
um i mean from my direct experience
right now it's not from the brain
but i mean i take the middle way it's i
mean brain is part of reality
right you see people are some people are
like oh you can't understand the nature
of reality because everything is
filtered to the brain everything is
created by the grain
by the brain but then brain is part of
reality right so there there are
actually a few schools to think about a
few different ways to think about this
one is that okay there is a real world
out there and then the brain models that
world and enlightenment is just how you
model the world exactly
as it is quote unquote as it is without
any filterings but it's still a model of
the world you can still never really
understand or know the world as it is
some people take that stand
and there are people who think that
consciousness or this empty kindness is
the nature of
the universe is that once you understand
the mind you understand the universe
because the universe is made up of the
mind
and there's people that are kind of in
between um
they're like okay it's both uh they're
codependent rising they stay in the
middle way
uh i would say from direct experience or
at least the first time that i glimpsed
this
you know emptiness i was 100 certain
this is the nature of the universe i was
like i've cracked
the secret of the universe i think a lot
of people have
a lot of people think that um especially
the first time they glimpse this thing
uh even very pragmatic and scientific
teachers they will go and be like
oh when i was younger when i was still
in the path there were moments in my
life where
i was so certain that um my my
my being was completely plugged into the
the
eye socket of reality
yeah and then that also reminds us of
things like the
um we can even we can even pull that up
briefly
in our in our images that sort of
reminds us of things like
like this where you have i'm an image
it's coming it's coming it's coming
we have things like
share screen on my hair
cutting my hair he says that's great
okay
here here it is here it is
okay there it is
oh yes the the cosmic octopus
exactly
um that's all that's always into what
frank's saying right now
it's an important visual for people i
think a better image
is you get rid of the body and they're
just the hands and they're just the eyes
floating space yes
just the eyes uh just lies in the hands
the
flowing space yeah we should show the
picture of uh the the picture that i
sent you of the card
when i said that that sort of
illustrated like the the sensations of
dependent origination
do you have that of course i do yes yes
yeah we should put that but right now
because that
that's kind of close to that pretty
close to that as well
um or later when we talk about dependent
origination i think it's kind of
the same but uh it's a little different
um but yeah anyway so
to answer your question uh the people
who
are a lot of hindu yeah that
well see the space you see the space the
empty carcasses space
okay so i would just like to help
clarify this
for people what frank and i
are talking about so and frank correct
me
if if i'm wrong here so
um is what you're saying
that there is when we get to this
place of recognizing the nature of mind
that there's sort of one
way of seeing it which is that well
this is it like this is god
infinitely fractaling itself as
creations and then having this
ability empty cognizant ability to know
the creations and
it's a fractal at this stage because i i
i would say because there is no form at
all fractal still presupposes that
there's some kind of form there's
some kind of like breaking down of a
bigger form um i would say
how should i put this i would say that
if if no one's ever told me anything
about like
mind brain or god uh i would say this
is the universe as it is right now
in all levels it's not it's not just
like a smaller fractal of
a bigger god this is it every single
being is experiencing exactly this
and this is the full thing
it does feel like that yeah so um we
pulled this up on one of our previous
shows and we'll just pull it up right
now as well
um so this is where that word um fractal
really
hopefully helps i mean similar to this
to this shirt that
that i'm wearing right now but the
general idea would be that in every
single one of these potential
points of on this big em
empty tablecloth of of of god
you have these eyeballs on all these
points
and so this is sort of you know one of
the ways of
of potentially perceiving this is that
um
it just takes a fractal-like uh
expression
um you you could you could say but even
that limits infinity
anyway yeah yeah yeah because that's a
form there there's still eyes and it's
their hands so so
exactly so there's infinite amounts of
ways to make the power to know
it doesn't have to have hands and eyes
and similarly
it doesn't uh have to appear like a
fractal
so okay so now i i i want to
anchor us back again so so now you have
one
one way which is sort of seeing that
the empty cognizant nature of mind is
one
way that infinity expresses itself as
the power to know
that's one and then two is that there's
even that is some sort of like
restrictive
um way of perceiving what's happening
and
it and actually um the way that this
dream uh universal dream substrate works
is potentially even more um
a quantum mechanical it's even more like
zero point
energy uh with these quantum fields
and then that that's the way that the
comprehension is working
the comprehension is working as an
entire universal decentralized
universalized dream substrate is that
right frank
that that would be the other way of
viewing it
um i'm a little lost okay
um so it what in one of the options
it's a little bit more like this
so in one one of the options is a little
bit
more like if we open this one up and
then we put it
next to this one as the second one
which is more like this so and i i think
that these two
go a little bit more together than we
usually give them credit for
so this right here so
i feel like these two go together more
than they go apart
if that makes sense so in one in one
example over here where you see my mouse
cursor
on avalokitesvara you have all of the
heads
and all of the hands and all of the eyes
that is the mind essence that is
comprehending the nature of reality
okay and then on this example on the
right
you have the complete
uh particle subatomic particle
decentralization
of the substrate that is
reality that is the universe and so
i i see these two as one rather than as
two
but do you see them as as did is this
what you meant when you said that
there's two different
ways of perceiving what the what the
nature
i think what we're talking about earlier
is whether or not this empty congress is
the nature of reality or the nature of
the brain
are we are we looking at the wall
through a filter of our senses
or are we really experiencing reality as
it is and i
don't know if those pictures have
anything to do with that
that i think that's another topic okay
let's
okay then let's
let's let's have what so give me one
more time um
what you just said because if you were
for example if you were to cut
my uh head off at the neck like they
used to do
you know hundreds of years ago um you
would undergo these
decapitations and um
it would be like you hit the off button
on this piece of life
oh yes yes that's why we're talking
about earlier yes exactly good good good
point
okay yeah okay so okay so
um so what what we
okay so let's just we may come back to
this but
this these two are more likely
one than they are two like
um that there's yeah and we we may get
back to that but let's stay
let's stick with where um we were just a
moment ago
which is that um all dualities get
transcended
and so the duality of physicalism and
consciousness gets transcended
yeah so yeah so so for example
this this unit is is
dependent on um the body
as the portal for the unit's perception
does does that make sense yeah so
basically you're talking about whether
or not our experience is filtered by
this biological organism
uh our perceptions our cognitions
um the nature is the nature of mind only
limited to this meat suit
if if someone kills me would i still
experience this empty carcass
that's what we're talking about and like
i said when
i told my friend like the other day uh
we're talking about the same thing and i
was like
if someone was to again if i did i fear
if i didn't know anything about science
or brains or physics or anything like
that or even death or whatever
if someone shoots me in the if someone
was to threaten me and she points a gun
at me and be like you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna andrew mitsu i'm going
to destroy me too
basically i'm going to kill your your
this entity as frankie
i will for sure tell him i'm gonna still
gonna be conscious from direct
experience because that's how conscious
that's how that's how from this
perspective of
non-duality how uh how consciousness is
really
in a sense apart from the body but it's
also the body is the manifestation of it
but let's say if i destroy
let's see if i destroy this piece of
pillow right here right now
i would for sure say that even a normal
person who doesn't know anything about
spirituality and who hasn't had an
awakening would tell you
if this piece of uh pillow gets
destroyed i would still be conscious
likewise if someone tells you hey frank
i'm going to destroy your meat suit i
will still tell them i'll be conscious
that's only from the context of direct
experience right now let's see if i
erase all my memories and all my
knowledge about the nature of
uh biology the nature of brain and age
of physics nature of life and death i
would tell them that
i'll tell me go ahead and destroy my
body if i have this you know this
infinite consciousness right now
that's what i'll tell them because from
the direct experience there is no death
okay so this seems to play into a topic
that we could potentially call
decentralization and universalization
so when you when you shift your identity
more and more to this empty cognizance
you begin um recognizing more and more
of yourself as the
um this this infinite emptyness
that gives rise to um
endless creation and that
you and that's suffused with awareness
or this this power to know
so when your identity shifts away from
your
finite physical body towards
that which is ineffable and
indescribable that
powers all of this basically
maybe that's why frank is saying what
he's saying
right now that his identity is now
more eternal than it is in his limited
frank meat suit is that right frank yes
you could say that
you could say that yeah okay so now but
now i'm not making a claim about
what the nature of mine is or the nature
of reality or nature yours i'm just
saying direct experience that's why it
feels like
experience right now that's why it feels
like i can't die yes okay
so so for for me um
what what feels um
more more accurate is the simultaneity
because when you talk to mainstream
and when you um chop off the frank yang
head
um the simultaneity is that
this piece of infinity deactivates
while your identity as the source of
infinite creation
remains so what
what you are is this ineffable giving
rise to infinity
infinity [ __ ] itself you're that you
are infinity expressing itself you are
that
i am that we are all that whether we
know that or not whether we've
recognized it or not
whether we've become a gnostic being or
not but
but the simultaneity is important where
it's like you for the frank yang costume
character right now
is a pair of the eyeballs on that avalo
kite
vara you know it's a pair of eyeballs
and if you
chop off the net at the at the neck the
head
the pair of eyeballs deactivates now
now your identity so do you see the
simultaneity where you can describe it
as both
like this individual okay okay
cool because i know that nissar godzilla
and much of the
um siddhar mishwar and just much much of
the
ramana that there's there's this um
lao said there's a lot of
a lot of the mystics the greatest
mystics have
went and identified themselves solely
as that absolute solely as that
and therefore whenever they would you
know do the things like what you were
just describing
that they would say i know i'm i'm
eternal you've assumed me to be a body
but i'm not the body
and so the simultaneity i feel like is
really important where we say that i am
both
that and i am also yeah yes
yes yeah definitely yeah that's what we
have been going on about
uh the last episodes well how you're
talking about how you're
both a nobody somebody and
uh everybody you know um because when
you
when you only identify with the
universalization of everything uh
in in a sense you could say that's also
a one side of the extreme that's
that's also a duality oh i am not the
body i am not the mind
are you really you don't have a body
so the heart sutra the heart switching
that gets to the bottom of this pretty
well the hearthstone shot is
called the perfect sutra it's the susha
that renders all the previous suits on
void
right so it's almost like the uh the
it's the super that makes you really
understand how emptiness is also empty
but form is also formed not just
emptiness form
from his emptiness so let me just sum up
the horizontal in a really really
easy to understand way there is no body
there is no mind there is no
consciousness there's no awareness
there's no free will
there's no self yet at the same time
there is a body
there is a world there's the mind
there's consciousness there's awareness
there's a cell there's free will
that's true unity right there exactly
yeah
that's one of my favorite passages yeah
yep but that still doesn't explain or
answer the question of whether this is
the product of uh brain or not but i
think it we can never know
so but if you take the middle weights
both it's both i mean the brain can only
arrive
that's it let's just say from the
relative level there is a difference
between the world
um the brain needs the world to manifest
itself too and vice versa
need one another exactly yeah um
so it's both it's both neither
there there was a phase in my
development where i was really
locked into that universality of things
of like the godhead and stuff and you
know the funny thing is
uh i i i think i i the the paradox is
this
the reason why in my content the last
like couple of months i've been telling
people to deconstruct even the
background to deconstruct
even consciousness to god consciousness
to objectify even infinity
uh because there is a phase where you're
going to be identified with infinity
you're going to be saying i am that i am
this universe i am god but there's still
a very subtle sense of identity there
that hasn't been dissolved because once
you dissolve even that
it wouldn't occur to you whether this is
a god or not whether this is
ridiculous you wouldn't think of those
words right exactly the funny thing is
after i deconstruct chronicle god that's
why i say
uh go from from non-awakening to
awakening you dissolve the ego but to go
from awakening
to say enlightenment you dissolve even
awareness
consciousness of god whatever is this
whatever dissolved the ego you dissolve
in that you
disidentify from him and that and after
i did that
i was i sank deeper into the absolute
after i deconstructed the absolute
after i stopped caring about what is the
ultimate what is the absolute if i am
this universal thing or not
i actually my day-to-day experience uh
became even more you know locked into
that thing
that i deconstructed that's the same
thing as we talked about earlier of how
to understand something you transcend it
the only way to transcend to the next
level whether it's spirituality or
anything live is to abandon the the
current one and by abandoning the
current one
first you have to understand it and if
second level you have to exhaust it
you have to exhaust it and once you
exhaust it it will eventually fall off
but once it fall out the paradox again
is you can experience it now even more
deeply
because now you truly understand when
you truly understand it you absorb it
you don't see it anymore
that's why insane even tell you to wash
away the stink of your awakening
yeah going back to that
you know transcend your realizations go
beyond even um
wake up even out of awakening yeah first
of
all
okay just well just that that's um
that's i think that's one more step
let's uh let's go let's go back a little
bit and then we'll also
reach that so now when you're noticing
the nature of mind if you can
sort of begin noticing it as something
like an empty cognizance
so you may you may yeah and we'll we'll
i'm glad you went back well well because
we're gonna i feel like we're gonna tie
that into the universalization right now
i'm glad you went back though so okay so
now if you
well this feels what's this feels like
what's most relevant for
many of our um fellow
um family uh on
on uh here here our family here
um um life reality
so when so when you when you're
recognizing the nature of mind as
potentially more and more of this empty
cognizance one of the most important
questions that i feel like you can ask
is
if if this if this nature of mind
here is empty cognizance is is is your
nature of mind empty cognizance and so
now you begin
wondering well is the nature of all of
our minds
empty cognizance
yeah okay so now you see so now i feel
like this is an important thing
to not necessarily um jump past too
quickly
which is that we've went from the
individual seeing
the object right to the individual
seeing their thoughts and then we've
gotten to the individual
seeing their mind essence as an empty
cognizance
okay and then now the next question to
potentially ask is
is that well is everyone's mind
essence empty cognizance okay good
question
okay okay so now we think now we take
this leap
we become transpersonal that's another
really good word
yeah um i would say yes uh
just from my direct experience of
talking to people reading accounts of
people's awakenings
uh and just the fact that uh the
experience of empty cognizant is they
can't be any other way because it's
empty has no form
because that there's no property to it
if there's no property it's identical to
everyone
it's homogeneous so and then there's
another question that sort of related
is that empty continuous nature of the
mind or of
experience even though it's the same
in every individual experience is that
is that is that still the nature of mind
as the brain
as if you try to is that still a part of
the brain or is that something that's
universal
you know what i'm saying so there's
actually like
like two two ways to look at this okay
if everyone on the planet gets
enlightened and everyone has a body in
that empty economist and everyone's sort
of like at least in the background
at least in the most primordial
fundamental way experiencing experience
exactly the same way no matter where
they are what they're looking at
who they are what gender they are what
sex they are they're experiencing
reality
through that same length of um
nothing this is a really relatable way
for people to get it
yeah so okay that's just presuppose that
that let's just assume that happens in
the next hundred years everybody's in
that state
but of course on the run that's the
absolute level
on the relative level i i'm still
looking at the same different stuff than
you are right
but then i i know for at the fundamental
level that
all the different forms that has been
manifested
um okay because pause for a moment
because this is really rich
okay so at the fundamental or the ground
or the essence level we can say that the
empty cognizance
here with atlas and with frank is the
same
potentially this is what we're saying is
potentially the same
but then what's different is that frank
is in taiwan and atlas is in los angeles
and so we're getting different
expressions where expressions
and so you can see the same thing with
like an expression of a woman or an
expression of a man
an expression of somebody that lives in
a certain place versus another place
that has some career versus a different
career no kids versus two kids or
whatever
and so these are um ways that you can
potentially begin juxtaposing well is
the essence
of mind the nature of mind empty
cognizance is the same
but the expression is unique and
different
yes yes so it's like the screen versus
the movie yeah everyone has the same
screen
because the screen doesn't have a
property and everyone's playing movie
that's a good analogy but then you get
some but then
with that's still uh that still doesn't
answer the question of whether whether
that is
uh really the nature of reality or not
and i don't think anyone knows the
answer to that some people think they do
but
you know what i'm saying so the essence
is the same screen yes
yeah and then and then the different
movies is the
expression yeah and so
so now what we're doing is we're trying
to trace back
from these objects to the thoughts to
the screen
itself the empty cognizant screen itself
and say well frank an atlas and all 8
billion
share the screen sentient life shares
a screen you know even potentially a dog
or even a fly has a very potentially
small
screen and they have potentially these
small flickering
images that are nowhere near our 4k
resolution images they have potentially
these tiny little
more black and white and gray style
flickering
images that are in maybe 360p or even
lower
resolution i don't even know what's
lower than that
um because we don't use that
as as humans but much much lower
than that okay screen that's why
they still have the same screen even
like dogs and cats have the same screen
there you go but but is this screen is
the same screen
at a different individual screen that's
a different computer has the same screen
or is this one giant computer
and with different like is it one giant
screen or many different screen or both
you know what i'm saying
did you did you get a chance to
see the this um
this jumbotron analogy
that i that i made um
like this this is how i how i visualized
it let's see if i can pull it up
right here
uh oh yeah it has to go to this side
all right
this yeah so that'll be
each individual has their screen and
then but if it's that one screen
also just the one screen you know what
i'm saying yeah
there's yeah infinite jumbotrons and
then
on the infinite jumbotrons which are
infinite gods which are infinite
universes this is a potential
um a potential way to describe the
nature on each one of these
god universe jumbotrons are
quadrillions quintillions of faces
which are all of the sentience
in that universe and what they're
experiencing
so you take the eight billion
perspectives that are on
planet earth and you put them on this
jumbotron and then you take the
trillions and quadrillions more
perspectives from all the other planets
in
all the other galaxies for all the other
sentients and you also put it on
this jumbotron and then you have the
universal jumbotron the god jumbotron
and so this is a very empty cognizant
processing or comprehending
[Music]
and then that's what's undergoing the
process of
comprehending infinite possibility
is this this the nature of mind
undergoing the process of comprehending
infinite possibility
and this is just one vehicle design that
we use
and universe is just one reality design
that we use
out of infinite potential so that's
okay so so now we got we got to
um the trans-personalization so you get
to empty cognizance
and you begin trans-personalizing
yourself
right so now most people feel this
with most people feel this with empathy
is one of their like first
gateways into this because they're like
oh you know when
when frank suffers you know compassion
is you suffer along with someone
right and so when frank suffers what i
do is i genuinely lovingly
caringly get behind his eyes and
lovingly care and suffer with him
and we grow through that together and
transcend that together
and so most people get these trans first
trans-personal tastes of experience when
they
begin merging themselves in a sense to
perspectives or like a mother
typically has a trans-personal
experience when she births a child
and she began she begins to be a lot
more selfless
and nurturing the child and even the
father as well
and so so now you've sort of shifted
yourself into a more transpersonal
perspective that's a really good word to
use and now when you
now i would say what frank has been
talking about the last
especially couple of months where he's
talking about the process
of taking what you're turning into the
ground
so in this case you've turned the mind
into the ground you've turned
consciousness into the ground you've
turned awareness into the ground
empty cognizance has become your ground
and so now
what you want to do is you want to
objectify your very ground
and so but when you do things like
objectify your ground
you begin more and more decentralizing
and universalizing yourself
even outside of this uh this kingdom of
god
being consciousness itself and so now
in a sense you become more and more of
the universe itself you
you take all these pieces that are that
you thought were you
and you then stored it into your empty
cognizant consciousness
and then now you decentralize and
universalize
even that is that approximately how you
see it
yeah so i was just going to go back to
this great analogy of how yeah after you
sort of objectify the uh even the ground
there's no more screen there's just
manifestations
that's true now duality because there's
a screen and there's
station if they're different there's
still a very subtle duality
so i guess you could say this is just
this right it's just this
um so another analogy that i like to use
is smashing the ground of being or
smashing god the godhead
into a billion infinite pieces and i
keep telling people you're not letting
you're not excluding the chronicle of
godhead
like you can experience the god even
more all the previous ages can
not be experienced even more deeply
after you decentralize them
you just simply take whatever you think
is the ground off of the pedestal
and you see how even the godhead is
dependent on rising
even consciousness or awareness is a
process of dependent origination
is the process of causes and conditions
this arises that arises
this season's diseases and that's a
your momentum of experience after you
penetrated through dependent origination
is actually in a quite a different
flavor than let's say the one mind the
absolute godhead perspective
i would say it's a lot more dynamic and
co-creative and bouncy and a lot more
actual
a lot more visceral um
i think they're not there's another
analogy that's a really good one before
awakening you're a person walking
through the world let's say if you're
just like taking a walk to the world you
know
i think walks every day you're a
separate being walking through the world
you're moving the wall is not moving
and once you wake up to that you know
infinity that godhead uh the war it's
like you're not this it's almost like
you become static now you're identified
with this infinite godhead
right now when you walk in it feels like
your body
is if you're like the new self
the first stage you're the small self
you're moving to the second stage you're
the big self
the big self never moves because it's
eternal timeless whatever right so when
you walk in the water it feels like you
are walking in it
but then there's still a subtle duality
there between that which doesn't move
and the character moving along with
other people the third stage after you
penetrate it through different
origination
when you walk it's just the world
turning it's like it's neither in both
the previous two stages uh when you walk
it feels like the whole universe is
turning your legs
it's both and when you're
eating it feels like you know it just
feels like that they call it the dharma
body
yeah they call it the donald body and i
wrote some of this down because uh i can
read a little bit of this the experience
of it
um so the the violin plays itself
without the player while writing this
the phone types itself while walking the
whole world is turning your legs
so while lifting the mitsu doesn't get
tired because the whole world is the
body
and every rap feels like every part of
the cosmo
is working together doing their best
flexing itself to move the weight
um some traditions call this the dhamma
body i call it the cosmic octopus
it's the magical tapestry of this
realization is visceral actual purely
sensual
immediate rather than conceptual
imaginary or absolute
uh when eating is the universe eating
when shading is the universe [ __ ] so
it feels like every note in this cosmic
symphony from the big bang to the big
crunch
is perfectly in tune to make every
breath and every sensation precisely the
way it is right now
and all interpenetration is in perfect
harmony and turning your head and moving
your arm one can perceive the intention
and thoughts preceding the movements
arising and vanish on their own volition
indistinguishable from the form of the
clouds and moving with other people
birds flying wind blowing sounds of
traffic and cars driving
whatevs should have could have would be
completely raised from your mental
landscape because even the imperfections
are perfect so
that's a little description of um
it feels like every action it feels like
it feels like every action you take
every thoughts that you have every
decision you make is sort of the total
excursion and the activity
uh the interdependency of the whole
universe
yes it's just like you're watching
animal planet you know when you watch
the animal planet
you don't think of like uh you don't
really think of like like
you you just see how all animals are
cold upon rising and
it's all interconnected and there's no
central agency that's making this happen
frank would you
would you um let's let's play
let's play like this for a moment um
okay we'll go ahead and give you guys
these
these uh visualizations which should be
so that's the the visualization we just
brought up earlier that could
that could match what we're talking
about yeah so okay so
yeah for so for just for just a moment
um
what it seems like is that when
you undergo a i'll switch back
um for just a moment um it seems like
what happens is that
there's a transition from
the object to what's more formless which
is
watching a thought appear and disappear
and then
becoming this subject which you could
say
which you could say feels more and more
like
empty cognizance or like this pure
awareness
what not right right and and so then
you question and say well is this empty
cognizance the nature of mind the same
for frank and for all eight billion of
us
okay so might this be god okay so now
you're
there and might god be infinity
expressing itself and so now you begin
sort of like
deconstructing and that sort of but that
leads us to
this type of stuff where you begin you
kind of become
each one of these
subatomic particles of the entire
universe
you become the universe itself you
become the fabric
or the substrate would you say those
words would you say you become the
fabric
or the substrate you become the quantum
mechanical flux
of the universe itself
um it's it's more like um
it's it's it's more like you become
none of it because there's only the
process there's only the links
there's only the links even ultimately
even the links are empty
but there there's no thing there is no
solid thing there's only the process
where all the parts are working together
to create this thing called the car
right
so just like every word in the
dictionary is dependent on every other
word
okay okay if i yes if i may maybe this
will help
um is there a
is there a
in what we're exploring with physics
there's this zero point energy
the absolute lowest energy that a
quantum mechanical system can be at
this is what you could say is the
nothingness okay
and then you have all of these excited
states you have all of this quantum
mechanical flux
and you have these quantum field
theoretic interactions that happen
here that then enable the arising of
what appears as matter
or form or frank yang or atlas and stuff
and so then you have these infinite
fireworking that's happening here
so you have this absolute nothing
absolute everything and you have
this empty cognizance as that which is
comprehending it
so that might be one way frank how does
that resonate
if at all um i would say the uh
so going back to the stages you were
talking about how before you're looking
at a pen
and then you become aware of the pan and
then you expand even that awareness to
the whole universe
yes and then you start to break down the
awareness and then you start to perceive
the world as to this process of
dependent
rising uh that would go along with the
stages of awakening we talked about
in the last episode first you're
identified with the ego that's the pen
and the second stage you're identified
with with with the consciousness
that's in the head and then the third uh
the third level you identify with being
god or infinity being
um and the fourth stage you're
identified with being nothing
in non-existence and that's when you
start to break down even the ground of
infinite being
and then there's another stage after
that where you sort of just
it's sort of like the war as it is the
actual world but then see the actual
word as it is you have to distinguish
the
the actual world as it is uh the natural
state
uh or the nature of mind uh there is the
there is the real critical real world
the world before awakening that you
perceive through this limited
perspective of the character
um and then there is this as the
spiritual world where it's kind of like
the stage of the god
stage of the infinite consciousness
that's the clinical spiritual world
and after you deconstruct giving your
spiritual identity and the ground of
being
or even you know god consciousness you
reach the actual world
okay so so when we're shifting let's
let's pick this up at
empty cognizance so when you're shifting
from
empty cognizance you're shifting into
what we had
up as the decentralized or universalized
let's say could we say that that's fair
that we make a shift from
empty cognizance into transpersonal and
into decentralized universalized
well empty is is is not
it's it's it it runs through all the
stages i would say
you know i would say so i would say so
as well
it's just that i would say so as well
there's just one distinction that seems
to be important here
which is that you sometimes there's
not necessarily a full um bathing in
what i would say
is this um bottom stage of nothingness
down here i i don't i or emptiness
it's it seems like there's maybe a
little bit of a taste of the emptiness
and then you just go right back to
expressing yourself
and you don't perpetually bathe in the
emptiness which would be bathing in
rigpa
over and over and over and over and over
again to really purify your expression
really well
and then this is just one way of
perceiving it where then you would have
this suffusion with awareness as the i
am-ness
and then you would have the eternal
infinite creation
and so um this is another image that i
would just like to see how you feel
about this
do you sometimes feel like it's rather
than frank yang
um that you feel like it's more like the
universe
itself like your piece of life
is more like so decentralized that it's
the universe itself
yes exactly that's why um earlier when i
was reading my post i said when you eat
it's just the universe eating
when you when you walk is the whole
universe walking but there is a
difference between experience that
dynamically
as actuality versus sort of just like
this this uh
immobilized witness um so i guess the
the difference is between having the the
universe just sitting there
watching itself through you versus
expressing itself in an
actual dynamic creative matter in
everyday life and that is the difference
in zolchen be between uh when when you
realize ripa as sort of the static thing
versus taking that
and then applying to every single moment
of your life and rick
of illumination is the expression of the
of the samadhi of suchness which is that
that
dharmakaya yeah yeah
yeah then we talk about the dharma body
and again the reason why it's called a
dharma body because it's because it's so
like visceral it's almost like you know
how the the okay that's just the frank
part the frankfurt every single part in
the frank body
is working together to make every single
action and every single like you know
uh function the way it is right it's
like a like a like a cosmic symphony
uh and then like you know um you know
the aesthetic of the bicep
can only co-dependent rising with you
know the rest of the muscles you know
you can't just
only have a big bicep uh there's the
symmetry of it all it's the working
together in this you know
uh symphony that gives rise to every
single little
particle in the body the way exactly the
way it is um
so this interdependency this
interconnectiveness this
interpenetration
the expression of that after you
penetrate through dependent origination
is a different flavor than say the one
mind or the i am-ness or the
perceive the world through brahman that
there is a
very subtle or maybe even a very big
difference in how you
say that say that one more time say that
sentence again i feel like that's an
important sentence say that again
um well your moment-to-moment experience
uh after having penetrated deep in
origination and i must emphasize you you
can you can't truly penetrate your
dependent region
and experience it uh beyond just
concepts you can't
you can't experience it directly unless
you've penetrated through all the stages
before unless you have realized no self
both the no self with the small ass the
eagle and no cell with a big ass
because because if you're still standing
on the ground of the big self of the
brahman
you can't really you can't really
perceive the interdependency
because they still perceive the world
through this you know eternal thing
and everything's happening in it right
and are you are you trying to say that
also the screen is
also dependent on the movie that it's
projected yes
exactly what i'm saying the conscious
center's awareness is dependent on
the objects perception is dependent on
objects without the object it won't be
perception without perception there
won't be mind without mind it won't be
consciousness so on and on and on
and yes yes so everything is
co-dependent arising
through causes conditioning okay so so
so then so then
the screen that we
were talking about being potentially the
same
across all eight billion humans the
empty cognizant mind
is not a ground it's not something quote
final but rather when you decentralize
or universalize
even that there's the recognition that
the that the empty cognizance is
dependent on the entire universe and
every subatomic particle
and the whole movie that's at play for
you right now right
right right right exactly so um
so you can say even there's no such
thing as permanent consciousness there's
no such thing as the screen
from that perspective there's just a
movie there there's only reflections
right and um and reflections average i
guess you could say there is only
infinite potentiality there's only
infinite potentiality
right there's only manifestation there's
only the mirror
sorry there is no mirror there's only
the reflections right
so uh yeah so so so it's only
infinite fireworks you could yeah you
could
you could say that that there's no not
even the sky there i i i
not even yeah yeah there's no background
to anything no background there's not a
background
infinite fireworks but we're not with
the seer watching them
you are the infinite fireworks yes yes
yeah
it's it's more like it's it's more like
the infinite firework it's not yours or
mine it's the cold arising of all the
different parts
so that's where you get through the
infinity co arises as
eternal fireworks yes uh
yes yes yeah you can say the infinite
potentiality what is the infinite
potential
other than the manifestation of
co-dependent rising
right so there won't be this thing
called the infinite potentiality without
the parts
so the parts is the whole and vice versa
the parts it's always dependent on the
hall and the whole is also dependent on
the parts
right so that also sort of explain and
answer some of the questions we had
earlier
is this really the nature of reality or
is this just the product of our
individual minds
it's co-dependent they're co-dependent
rising they're both arise through the
causes and conditions of
um all the different links and the
different nodes of the universe
so is it like this infinite potentiality
manifests as codependent arising
fireworks
yeah you could say that yeah
wow you or you could just just say that
reality
i guess you could we could bring this to
the the problem of free well the
universe
is not predetermined neither is it
totally random the universe is a process
called creation
that's the simplest way to put it it's
neither a predetermined like a goddess
in the determination it's neither just
random it's neither just all just you
know i can do whatever i want it's all
random
there's no meaning at all so you sort of
find the middle way between eternalism
and the absolutism of like brahman of
the the hinduism of like christianity
and versus the nihilism or even the
emptiness of buddhism adult there's just
no self
so you find the middle way and transcend
both sides of those dualities
um this might also be a good time to
read
your free will post
as well oh yeah we can talk about
freeway i think that's all related
yeah maybe maybe actually give give it a
moment just give it a quick moment let's
sink in this first a little bit deeper
and then we'll and we'll then we'll get
through it yeah because you just brought
it up and it was really salient but i'd
like to potentially stay with this just
another moment
so
okay so we have an
ineffable which is pure potentiality
infinite potentiality something that's
unbounded something that you'll never
come to the end of exploring
right right so this is sort of like this
this is sort of the first principle
you could say the first principle
logically speaking if you were to create
an
axiomatic mathematical proof style
science breakdown you would say that you
have to assume
that there's pure potentiality infinite
boundless potential and that's
potentially what we are
so then you have to start with that as
an assumption which is directly
experienced by many mystics as the
nature of reality
okay so um including myself and frank
and many people that awaken come to this
realization
okay so then now now we're breaking this
down axiomatically proof-based science
math for people
so now you start with this pure
potentiality it's boundless infinite
and then the the next sort of
step is that there's a manifestation
mechanism for that
and the mechanism of manifestation
in this case in our n of one our sample
size is only one here
is a universe with planets orbiting
stars
that have biology that secretes
sentience and that then turns around and
recognizes its its nature
now this is one mechanism of expression
and so the universe
co-dependently arises as the fireworks
frank atlas all eight billion of us
all the planets from uh
from a level of
whatever is at the very nothingness
of things just like this uh
zero point energy as well
all the way up to the actual fireworking
of this frankie
costume and a massive codependent
substrate
doing said said process how does that
resonate well
it's difficult yeah that that is
that is one way to put it it's like um
it's like
everything from the big bang to the big
crunch is is codependent rising to make
every single
um thought you have the way it is
um yeah so yeah so that's that that
i actually wrote that down so i was
looking at my notes i actually used the
word the big bang and the big crunch
um because even just every single word
that i'm ordering right now every single
breath i'm taking right now
is depending on rising through this
infinite webs of causes and conditions
and every single events and phenomena
and sensation within this web
is connected to infinite other webs and
but what i want to say is that that's
one way to look at it that's one way to
conceptualize it but i'm
i guess i was trying to get down to the
the moment uh
i was trying to get down to the uh
to the embodied manifestation of the
embodied experience of that
perfect let's do that next let's do that
now yeah okay so
the difference is that that's exactly
one one really good way to
to visualize it but then there is also
the direct experience of that
which you can't directly perceive the
big bang with the big crowns you can't
so in the direct experience of it um
it actually the the direct experience of
dependent rage nation
is well i just i sort of i sort of read
it uh what
what i wrote earlier it's it's it's it's
it's like every uh
it's it's like they're they're the
before it was more like the
the big like one mind thing was just
like um
you're walking you're walking in it
right and you you're this headless like
you know
unbounded space and you're walking
through the space and you become that
space after you after you identify the
ego and you start to identify with this
infinite space
and everything's moving through it you
feel like you're eternal you feel like
you're this ground up being and
everything's manifesting out of it
and then after you deconstruct them that
and start to experience the world
through this interconnectivity
um yeah
then you start to experience the world
sort of like um
very close to the way that those
pictures depict
and then now now from that place
how does one undergo this process of a
spontaneous pure expression is it just
natural every time that you sort of
unite more this is how it feels like
right now
for for me where i'm at is that every
time i
recognize mind essence and empty
cognizance every time i recognize that
every time i feel like the universe and
all feels like the universe every time
that happens
it feels like the expression is pure
and so yeah that's a good joke
yeah it feels like okay it's
rather than just everything's it's kind
of like a rising pass in a way through
this infinite field
of eternalism it's more like every
everything is spontaneous and everything
is being created right now
it's not it's not arising and passing
through a background or a source
is that everything is this everything is
already the source itself
there's normal distinction between the
source manifestations yeah
but but first you undergo a process of
negating your
way to unite with said uh essence
and then you see then you include and
see it all as source dancing
yeah and then there's sort of dancing
the the the rhythm of the source dancing
everything is
dependent depending on rising through
with and s each other so it's it's like
it's like moving from
like big cosmology to like quantum
entanglement you know how like you know
physics right
uh there's there's newton unions are
like this absolutism like brahman kind
of got right
and then after newton you have like the
einsteins and the quantum mechanics
that einstein was taking everything to
be more relative right it's like oh
nothing is dependent on this absolute
timeless like gigantic cosmic clock
like newton said everything is sort of
relative right you change one thing you
change the other everything is dependent
on rising through each other
right the time and space is not really
like this this thing we
we assume to be the background of
experience time in space itself
is also the same process of codependent
rising
just like consciousness awareness you
take the background out and then
you go even beyond that and say oh
there's this quantum entanglement in
quantum mechanics kind of thing where
it goes it breaks down even deeper and
like it's a little
even even more um sort of spontaneous
than what einstein assumed so i guess
that that could be
a good analogy okay so so so the
simultaneity
of being both the um
um the universe and also potentially the
metaverse
when we play with that pure potentiality
and also
being the most point energy this very
quantum mechanical
fields being that as well the quantum
entangled
everythingness at the same time and so
that's really interesting to see it at
the most planck level
and the cosmic level and merging those
that's the you know cl this whole
process of it closing on itself
seeing it at the most macro the most
micro and this
you know you know there's a meso level
people forget about the meso
because they only go to macro and micro
meso is like human
level and so that's unit locality where
you i think
exactly what you're talking about i
think i think i think that the
nothingness the singularity and
the the big crunch and the big bang is
the same you know the the singularity is
infinity so the everythingness and the
nothingness is the same but then in the
middle there's the manifestation of it
on the sort of the more actual level
and that's what i mean when i say this
the experience of dependent region feels
actual it feels visceral it's not it
doesn't feel spiritual
like that's like visceral yeah yeah it
feels right
yeah and the the really that's referring
back to the the analogy
so i have a question i have a question
yeah and i know you've been i know
you've been
talking about it from the perspective of
the the animal as well which i think is
really interesting
my question would be this um it's been
written about as like a
like a it's like a not so merry-go-round
it's sort of what it's called um where
you're basically like the samadhi bell
gets hit and all of a sudden you
recognize empty cognizance
or you recognize yourself as the
universe and not your contracted
character
in it and so what is it like because you
just described it as this visceral
experience is so what what is that
like when it's for you right now when
it's not
something that you revisit something
that's not like a samadhi bell that
rings a couple of times
that that that would lead me to the the
post about um free on determinism um
okay great yeah it sort of feels like
in here there is no observing anymore
because you if they constructed the
observer
and you have deconstructed and dissolve
the thinkers so it's not a state you go
back and forth to
it's just the way it is happening right
now like
it doesn't feel like you're you're doing
it that's why i said every action feels
like the total exertion and the activity
in the tapestry
of the whole universe through those
different lengths of
dependent horizon and causes and
conditions so
in in more like the way you can
visualize it
i guess is it could be could be could be
put it this way let's say if you eat a
grain of
just eat a bowl of rice you're not just
eating the rice
it feels like let's see if i'm eating a
bowl of rice and there's like people
sitting next to me and there's birds
flying around me and then there's like
wind blowing and then it's like all the
different parts
are working together in like a symphony
to make every single bite of the the
rice
perfect the way it is it's like this
cosmic symphony and everything's playing
too and it's like
it's not just like you as the observers
the god might in this very static kind
of eternalism way sitting in the
absolute cloud
of eternal ground of being eaten in the
clouds neither is it just the individual
itself in the clouds
sorry it didn't arise it's like it's
those different parts and the different
relations into penetrations that's
making this particular action possible
so it's both the individual and the
universal right
and you can also like contemplate how
like the the rice is only dependent
rising through like the farmer
uh or the weed that we feel you know and
the we feel it's only can only be
possible
and it's rising through the sky the rain
the weather and this web of connection
goes
you know to infinity to infinite
potentiality so
in a sense it's it really takes uh
not just the center point of the you
know of the mitsu out of the equation
but the center point of the universe out
of the equation
um and it's a it's a really effort i
think the one word that i could use to
describe it is effortlessness
effortlessness and freedom and
spontaneity yeah
yeah it's not something you have to
observe abiding going back and forth to
it's not like a state where there's
higher lower it's just whatever is
manifesting right now
and one of its manifest right now is
always without exception
uh the process of colorizing co-creation
into penetration interdependency
into play um
so so over time there's a shift even
more
from this
what appears to be a what appears to be
like a samadhi bell that is like gung
and you're like in this empty cognizance
you recognize
it or you recognize yourself as the
universe
so there's a shift from this like dung
that like happens and then you're
you're you're there and then that sort
of becomes more and more
of it's like when you're doing the
three-pointers it becomes more and more
effortless that that becomes the natural
rhythm the natural so you shift less and
less away from
necessarily being the contracted
identity and you shift more and more
and then and then that process even
sort of closes the loop on itself where
it's just
effortlessness freedom spontaneity
of expression but purely i think
the most important word that i've
realized is purity
like purification yeah christine is like
very pristine
like immediate
yes yet um
you can you can spontaneously express
yourself
from a place of still separation or ego
or identity or lack or
needing validation from people which is
all a fair
expression of infinity but the point is
is that if you really
want to purify yourself all the way
into this abiding essence repeat
repeatedly it it almost enables the
expression to be more pure it enables
the expression to be more spontaneously
in service um it enables it to have more
honor
like i don't feel like people come off
compassionately
after not abiding in the essence of the
nature
that's what i'm trying to get at um
anyway cool so one of the
um i want to talk about that bell really
is this just part of my head i think
that nothing is a really good
analogy it's not just like oh the bell
rings and you try to abide in the space
where the bell is
rising and vanishing to try to be
mindful of the belt it's not even just
that it's like the bell
is there's no more like bell this it's
just like
what is the bell what is the sound of
the bell but the color rising of the
person hitting the bell and what is the
person
the person made up of like infinite
number of parts right and then the bell
the sound of the bell is dependent on
all the different factors that
everybody in sitting in the meditation
hall it depends on all of them
to manifest the belt and man the bell
benefits through them
so it's like you are in everybody
everybody is inside you kind of thing
right the bell is inside everybody
everybody is inside the boat everything
everybody
is inside everything and everything is
inside everything everybody
so it's not just that bell it's not just
you being mindful
of the belt it's like the belt is the
manifestation of all these different
parts
you know you know the what is that the
instrument that's hitting the belt the
sound the vibrations
the air you know the sound can't exist
without the air
it's that yeah it's all those different
parts
coming together in a perfect moment
that's why that's why that
after you kind of see through the region
is you you sort of lose a sense of
control
you start to lose a sense of agency but
paradoxically
there's a lot of freedom in losing the
sense of agency and i guess we can
shift into the the talk about free will
versus determinism
um because i think it's related you know
so
would you say that there's a place of
very little will at first
and then you regain more and more
sovereignty and will
and then once you sort of me once you
sort of
meet this awakening end point you can
say
there's no more will or choice
so it's go it's going from
uh no will to unfreezing your will
gaining lots of sovereignty lots of
spiritual mass
and then going back to a place of
merging with
just infinity where
there's uh no choice again because
you're
only spontaneously expressing yourself
from a compassionate place yeah that's
it that's a good way to put it i'll say
the first is the personal will and then
there's a universal well and
after that the universe and the person
will merge into one and you don't even
think about will or not well anymore
yeah that's how i would put it yeah
yeah okay and then what now this is
this is another interesting um um
way to to ask you about this
but what like what is the difference
when you're going to this place of
essence again it's a separate place
right for a for a period of time is your
your
you're hitting this bell and going to
this place of essence
and then expressing from there and then
those over time collapse into the same
thing
um okay but you're becoming
more and more thought-free wakeful you
know it's written here right now
and i just want to leverage this it's
just that's what it feels like it feels
more and more thought-free wakeful
but then when something arises it's a
rising as what's called like a white
thought instead of a black thought
where the white thought is yeah where
the white thought is like it's
it's a it's it's pure in the sense that
it's coming from a place of wanting to
serve
life or to serve awakening
to be compassionate okay okay so you're
talking about okay i think i heard some
like a talk or something that
distinguishing between like uh good and
bad desire versus craving
like you can have good desire and bad
desire like a positive desire and a
negative desire
and how desire is different craving i
don't know that that's what you're
talking about
well in this in
um
i guess if you want to bring compassion
and service to others to the to the
picture i guess you could say that after
you
you penetrate through the
interdependency and interconnectedness
of all beings and objects it's
impossible not to
uh it's impossible not to manifest
compassion
perfect because even even the things you
do for yourself is dependent on like all
those different links of other people
and objects you know what i'm saying so
so every single action you do and take
is the manifestation of
compassion in that sense once you see
through how there it that
there is only the activity of those the
process of
you know connectivities into penetration
another way to put it is like first
you're the ego and then you're the
godhead
even though you could be sitting in the
absolute transcendence and not give a
[ __ ] about the world
uh that's why a lot of people they just
say lots of in the same picture
the last one you go back to the
marketplace right i guess that's kind of
like how it is you know if you're just
sitting in your in your crown of nirvana
yeah some people uh find that to be kind
of quite imbalanced
sort of they just stop giving a [ __ ]
about the world versus where you sort of
deconstruct even for nirvana
you deconstruct even the godhead and
then you come back down to the world
and express this uh purity of pristine
awareness where it's not centralized
anywhere there's no observer there's no
thinker it's just manifestations
[Music]
you know like we talked about the zen 10
octane picture before but i
went back and looked at it again
yesterday it's funny because there is a
stage where
after emptiness after the circle
the next picture is this is just a
picture of the world and in the
description it did talk about like the
process of
colorizing independent origination and
then after that
you you you sort of let go of that
you're like oh even that idea
and he just embodied it so in in essence
you get to the recognition that i
am brahman or i am dao or i am god
i am infinity i am nothingness you get
to this recognition
and then you say that that ultimate is
the world and those two are one and it's
done
is that in essence you you could put it
like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then the thing is so
like when
when after a while you just sort of stop
thinking about you just kind of stop
lacing those terms
um on top of reality like yeah you you
just don't
well like brahmans anymore you just
don't proceed to walk through through
like the the lens of
any spiritual teachings anymore um that
but but
you still you still get to keep like the
experience of it you still you still get
to
embody the the benefit of it but that's
what i've been saying is that after a
while you let go of even
what i talked about earlier you even let
go of dependent room nation and you
learn like all the notes and the links
and all that different stuff
and it's just this right here um
[Music]
even the whole notion of like no
doership or like you know
um you know awareness of awareness that
that eventually
that all gets dissolved from your mental
landscape
um yeah
so just manifestation simply this
yeah the thing is about the thing the
thing about this is like this is really
hard to express
because when you just tell people it's
just the way it is most people can
confuse them like okay there's nothing
to do
there's no no no there's no uh
realizations to be had there's no inside
the beginning it's just the way it is
right now right well i'm happy or not
but it's not really like that either so
that's why i distinguish between the
the real world of the ego world like
what most people experience
or before awakening is the critical real
world to the separate self and then
there's a spiritual world
where you experience the world through
this like absolute transcendence nirvana
godhead and then there is the actual
world and the actual war is what we
talked about earlier how like you know
everything is dynamic bouncy and
spontaneous
and able to use try to slap on it it's
just not it
dynamic bouncy spontaneous no labels
is that and then there's a and then up
to the point is like
what what is the nature of mind what is
the nature of reality what is the
ultimate
that also you let go of you just stop
questioning it
you just you just you just live life
yeah
you just live life you know what idea
shantae said he said something that's
really fascinating
he said uh he tell people not to get
stuck enlightenment just
get gay walk and move on with your life
but he still talks about enlightenment
you can still tease you can still talk
about it but but there really is a
difference between like
hijacking realizations and hijacking um
spirituality and then seeing the world
through that lens
uh versus uh talking about it purely
from the perspective
of how you see through it as just more
fabrications
how there's just more stuff of the mind
and yeah
so you ask the question who am i what is
reality
you get to the answer and then you help
other life
get to the answer in their own unique
way like you literally
deserve life but you don't hijack it
with a halo
but instead you do it like when when we
just had
you know daniel ingram on the show which
we talked about as well
where you basically you're weaving
spirituality
into the scientific paradigms
clinical trials biometric correlates of
awakening with eegs and
fmris and ekgs and all these different
ways to put awakening into the
mainstream in a sense so people can
um become more coherent
with life itself and less a separate
contracted
energy yeah that all depends on what you
want to do afterwards you know you can
do whatever you want but
yeah it's a really good way to express
compassion
around awakening yeah yeah yeah for dana
ingram that's this thing and then for
other people that's their thing if they
want to play basketball afterward play
basketball
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do um
do whatever the [ __ ] you want but just
know that if you if you truly know
if you truly know there was gonna be an
inclination for you to find a way to
serve of course find a way to serve
yeah yeah for me it's doing this it's
doing here
and you are too yeah and but but we do
it through a different sort of uh
we take other things and we try to we
try to inject it with different things
so that's cool
yeah yeah so
that's that's awesome i think i feel
like that's
that's pretty much most of what we want
to talk about i've been talking to zach
by the way he's running a little bit
late for our second um
for our second show that we're going to
do let's talk about the free will thing
okay yeah go ahead and um pull that up
yeah he's uh
i'm just going to read this po this post
so after i i have seen so i just forget
it all right
so i wrote uh wait wait wait wait can
you can you send it to me so i can pull
it up on the screen
as well oh sure uh should i should i um
so that i i give you some techniques
here also on how to access this
um so um
yeah so there are some exercises in
there i mean it's pretty simple
but um
are you gonna send it via email what's
up
so i think we did get to the bottom of
the question though in the beginning
what is the nature of mine
yes
yeah jim newman kind of kind of guy i i
like him i like him
but i'm just saying
there really is nothing more to say
about the nature of mind than to say
this is this is it right here right now
it's just that simply this is just that
but it's just that simply this you have
to simultaneously have that
while you also have the recognition
that like oh i'm going to go from
objects to becoming more subtle
meta metacognizing my thoughts yeah you
have to go through
the the process to to really say this is
it and really
like fully like complete going back to
that word comprehend itself
grock itself yeah yeah right right
reality grocks itself or comprehends
itself yeah
the the universe uh
fab into itself yes
all right let me see if i can pull it up
did you send it
yep all right
so i guess this could sum up a lot of
stuff that we talked about
earlier um i'm going to read it ready
so wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you said did you send it via
email
i want i wanted to pull it up on the
screen for people
that's what i mean they could read along
with it oh okay okay okay
yeah did you you did send it uh-huh
just
well
i guess i guess you could say that the
nature of reality or the nature of mind
can only be accessed fully when the
character
drops his desire or inclination to
understand the nature of reality and the
nature of mind
that's another fact that's another
paradox
i love that one i love that one that's a
good one
so it's not like i'm discounting all
this talks about the nature of mind it's
that
you have to like climb the mountain and
then throw it you have to climb leather
and throw it away
to climb the ladder and throw it away
yeah so the ladder
the ladder is so important and if you
want to help other people recognize you
have to throw in the letter you can't
just be like
uh there's no letter that's why that's
why even though i love jim newman i
think his method is too extreme for most
people like
unless you're there already it's hard to
understand what he's talking about
you know so
then then realize there was no climbing
anywhere
there's no climbing there's no climbing
there's no ladder but yeah i remember we
talked about at the same time there
is at the same time there is yeah that's
so great
okay let me see if it came through it
still hasn't come through bro
that's weird bro
are you sending it from your icloud
email because i
feel like that has an issue sometimes
okay
i'm sending it again there okay i sent
it
oh dude i can't have i can't wait to
have that comment it's going to be
it's not like you want it perfect okay
cool
okay wait wait wait let me pull it up
let me pull it up hold on hold on
hold on
hold on okay
okay
okay i got it i got it hold on and one
sack one sec
um and one cyclone second sec
let me switch this to um
to this and then oh that's the wrong one
oh that's so fun
it's hella trippy um we gotta do this
actually instead
it's this one over here there we go
okay all right and all right there it is
and now let me zoom in a little
and scroll over to the side okay
now oh no
no yeah now people can read along yeah
okay so we're we're here
yeah so at some point in your journey
you're going to lose all sense of agency
the personal well will be replaced by
the universal well but they're
ultimately the same because park
constant whole and vice versa
so when you untie the knot of perception
and lose the vintage point the center
the doer controller along with the
sealed hear thinker perceiver nor will
also vanish
so it feels a bit like chronicle you as
a separate self cannot make a decision
but every thought and movement is the
total exertion and the activities
of the entire universe how can the self
does or think anything at
all if you cannot even locate it hahaha
rather than
step on the holistic your momentum home
experience becomes extremely empowering
and
liberating liberating permanent flow
that transcends the temporary experience
of
being the zone because it's not a big
experience all right so life goes on
simply unfolding as it is
you'll probably do the same thing you've
always done but not always but without
the quantico doers slowing everything
down
things become much more efficient and
effortless it's kind of like when you uh
deconstruct the seer and the
and the hearer the sounds just hear
themselves
right the perception just appears
and there's no filter between the seer
and the scene the see
the here in the herd so yeah things are
just quicker i don't know
when you work out or get tired that's
why i go into the body so as your body
might becomes air the violin plays
itself without the player while writing
this
the phone types itself while walking the
whole world is turning your legs and
vice versa
so while lifting the mitsu doesn't get
tired because the entire world is your
body and every rat feels like every part
of the cosmo is working together
flexing itself to move the weight uh
yeah some tradition called this the
dharma body or the dhammakaya
so i call it the cosmic octopus
because like the uh the the
manifestation of the realization is
visceral actual
essential immediate rather than
conceptual or imaginary
so when eating is the entire universe
eating when [ __ ] is the universe
[ __ ] and every no from the cosmic
symphony from the big bang to the big
crunch is perfectly in tune
to make every breath and every sensation
precise the way it is
all into penetration in perfect harmony
turning the head or lifting the arm one
can perceive the intention in the
thoughts
preceding the movement to rising and
vanishing on their own volition
and distinguishable from the forming of
the clouds and moving on other people
burst flying wind blowing sounds of the
traffic
cars driving the could have should haves
would have to be completely raised
fundamental landscape
even imperfections are perfect but there
was a study where neuroscientists ask
participants to push a button whenever
they feel like it or they're inclined to
do so
the signals are pushing a button already
started at the clinical subconscious
level before they consciously decide to
do it
you can actually perceive and experience
this in real time when you abide in the
still point of true nature
that fill in the blank that manifests
all the existence and since there's
nothing but manifestation
and no distinction between background
foreground everything is
from the blank and there's nothing to
abiding
as an exercise try to do anything
intentionally you'll see that you can't
make anything happen
that isn't already happening by itself
any sense of a clinical you controlling
interesting
intelligence is like it's absurd it's
like believing in santa claus
even the thought or the feeling of
clinical i aim and control is an
afterthought
a conceptual layover that is also
happening by itself through the force of
nature
as an exercise sit down and watch your
breath thoughts or even skin the body
and you'll see that how all these
sensations are not just aware of
themselves and happening on their own
and it's the doing of the universe but
see even the intention of paying
attention to that
or direct attention to anything at all
is happening on its own it's the doing
of the universe
even the awareness of that is happening
on its own is the threat of the universe
so
you're basically repositionalizing not
just to be positionalizer
but the vibrationalizing itself so if
you passionalize the positionalizer and
we functionalize it so you sneak up on
any cluster of sensation that feels like
it's cortical in control
of another cluster of sensation then you
sneak up on that which is doing the
sneaking
and then on and on and on so you keep
going meta just like yourself inquiry
uh until the circuit closes on itself
and there's no more duality between the
subject and object and there's no more
curry meta
so there's no more like mirror there's
no more screen no more metacognition at
this point
so as another exercise stop before you
perform a task very mundane test like
turning the doorknob
see if you can catch the intention and
the thoughts that signal in this action
way before that not way before but like
before you start to turn the doorknob
you can actually proceed that's really
crazy with this realization
it wouldn't occur to you whether there's
free will or not free raw
because uh that only belongs to the
dualistic mind
right it will never equate you to nature
or the universe whether it's free or not
reality is neither predetermined or
random but cause the conditions of the
cosmos
since nothing is solid there are no
nodes only links of interdependency and
connectivity
and on the ultimate level if the links
are empty so there are no cause and
effects only spontaneity and
simultaneity
because time and space also don't exist
apart from the process of causative
condition
on the relative level you can truly
glimpse you can only truly glimpse the
above after you reach the stage five of
my map of awakening after realizing true
self of no self
by deconstructing both the ego and
awareness and then penetrate further
into dependent origination by smashing
the godhead
into a bill in pieces and you let that
go even so
everything everyone is inside you where
you say you're inside everything
everyone that's unit locality
so experiencing this quantum
entanglement real time
the operating system is upgraded from
the universal consciousness phase
which paradoxically cannot be
experienced even more deeply
your moment-to-moment experience becomes
a pristine bouncy luminous fairy tale
if everything is happening by itself
then nothing is happening by itself
ultimately any spiritual notions like
awareness of awareness no doership or
even consciousness will completely
be erased and disappear from your mental
landscape so the summing up the heart to
try again there is no body no mind no
consciousness no world
no self no free will yet at the same
time there is a body of my pure
consciousness
there is a self a world and free will so
in total unity
one can experience one or the other both
in or neither that is all
okay
[Music]
that is my little power point
presentation
bro
so
so would you say that that post
zach's calling should we take a break
and bring him on
yeah we can continue to talk about
my input my interface and everything i
will be ready to roll
okay great frank and i are uh we'll be
ready in
a little bit as well on our end so i'll
send you bro
we should talk about basketball when
he's on because they want to contend to
the real world
perfect perfect i'm going to send you um
a message in a moment with the link
back for surgery all right i'll send you
a message
with the link in a moment all right okay
okay i think we can end it here i mean
that
holds pretty much thanksgiving yeah
all right all right
i think our session could end here
because i think the poster i just read
pretty much
summarized everything we talked about in
a more like uh
organized matter i agree and would you
say that the essence of it
is dependent origination i would say so
yeah
yeah i would say the essence of it i
think dependent region is buddha's last
insight
that was the inside he had uh before his
his final enlightenment
his his final awakening uh different
origination why is there suffering
and you know what's fascinating about
that
you know what's fascinating about
dependent origination is the first
link of dependent origination which is
do you know mind essence
i love that if you don't know
mind essence then that creates
all of the dependent origination around
ignorance
being expression but the the that's also
basically that the my essence is also
part of this loop it's not like my
essence gives rise to this
all those webs it's part of the web
that's that's the buddha's insight
but where but where is your expression
for where is the first
link of your expression is do you know
the nature of mind or not
you have to know that first yes yes if
you because the first link is if you
know the nature of mind it's a pure
group expression if you don't know the
nature of mind it's going to be
contracted it goes
yes so exactly so you have to that's why
the steps you have to abide in the white
mind first the imness before you can
penetrate it
depend on your generation and the funny
thing is now the uh that you said that
because um
so basically what is suffering is also
dependent rising right suffering is only
dependent on the object of suffering
and the object of suffering is only
depending on the perception a perception
is dependent on
intention intention is dependent on
consciousness
and the consciousness is also dependent
on the the the suffering object and all
the other links right
so yeah
frank i adore you brother wait a second
i got one more thing to say amazing i
don't think last thing last thing
so some people are gonna be like wait
but what's perceiving all this different
origination
right right and then but then people
like dana ingram or
certain uh practitioners of certain
traditions that come and say
what about a secession when
consciousness disappear you go into
unconsciousness
isn't unconsciousness and consciousness
existence and non-existence
also co-dependent arising through each
other that's why i say enlightenment or
the absolute
is the merging and the transcendence of
both being and now being absolute
infinity
and absolute nothingness going back to
your little illustration
perfect
beautiful next time with your sweet
shirts bro you should wear it
i love you so much frank yang everyone
the [ __ ]
og straight up the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] polymath [ __ ]
synthesizing across
all these different traditions going
through all these different genres
and understanding the nature and
also being an absolute normie dissolving
his halo
[ __ ] dope bro i love you so much
you're lit i'm so pumped to create with
you more
[ __ ] g bro you're the [ __ ] g i
love you alice
i love you brother we have another we
have a next episode
we have the next episode threesome
threesome with zach marlowe
baby break we can take a little break we
are we're gonna take a break i love you
everyone thank you so much for
loving everybody thank you alex
i think next time you should bring in
like like basketball players or
bodybuilders
yeah actually that's something we're
going to talk about with zach on the
show
is uh how to how to trojan horse
spirituality into the mainstream
um yeah i i love i love
love you all thank you for all your
wonderful comments and um
and kindness and thank you for watching
and um check out the links in the bio
below to frank's
instagram also frank's youtube channel
he's got so much great content on there
go and subscribe check it out give him a
follow on ig as well
he posts so many good captions down
there under his posts
and also um subscribe to simulation if
you haven't yet
also leave us a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we'd love to
hear from you
like the video as well and share it with
other people that you feel like
it would positively influence go through
this practice of understanding my nature
more and more and share that with your
friends get pumped about understanding
my nature and also simply this
simultaneously
and that is all um that's all we'll
probably come back with in episode five
in a couple of months
maybe in the in the fall you'll see us
come back together again
and um we'll be potentially even making
more content
together um in the winter that's maybe
even around master classes around this
so
we're really excited for that and
infinite love for you guys
and we will talk to you soon
we okay